are you scrambling to find the perfect
gift for that kid or kid at heart that
loves all things Tech I talked with an
expert who shows us the coolest Tech
toys of the season
it is that time of year where it's all
about toys and there's no one else that
I trust more than the chief toy officer
of the toy Insider Lori shot how are you
hi I'm so glad to be sharing some of my
favorite tech toys with you and we're
going to start with something really
cool for our youngest kids and it's
called techie go and what you do is it's
kind of a plug and play you plug it in
the sensor is under the trampoline and
kids are going on Amazing
action-packed learning adventures and
the way they make decisions is based on
how and where they bounce on the
trampoline because how about if you have
a love of reading but you still want to
incorporate that with your love of
Technology well osmo is the company
that's all about this so for one thing I
just love everything in their line
because what they do is they take the
technology of the screen because we know
that our kids love the screen and they
incorporate it with in this case it's
the reading event but they have coding
they have math they have everything but
this is my favorite because it has voice
technology I've turned the sound down on
this one so that you and I can speak but
if I was following along I would be
reading and the app actually recognizes
my voice so if I stumble on a word it
will stop me it will take me through
each letter so that we sound it out
together and then I try again
for kids I just don't I don't want to
give it to the kids this is so cool tell
us about this so this is our Sky Viper a
force so it's a drone but this is all
you get other than the charger there's
no controller because it's all in your
hand but basically I just toss it in the
air and it flies I'm using my hand to
fly it so I can touch it it's just a
toss you touch it you can put your hand
underneath it it will go up it'll come
back to you when you get really good at
it by moving your hands you can actually
make it do some fancy tricks someone who
is beloved by everyone is Bill Nye the
Science Guy and and I hear you have
something really cool from him and this
is a virtual reality and augmented
reality science kit so what you get is
everything you need for over 30
experiments you get this gorgeous book
that's filled with 80 different 80 pages
of like a so much information on how to
do so when kids are following the
experiment they'll take their phone they
will put it onto the book the first
thing they will see is Bill Nye pop up
sort of cartoony he'll tell you about
the experiments you're going to do then
there are boxes that you put your phone
on you just follow the instructions and
you get all of these videos that you see
even though you're in your real world
when you're done with that like this is
a volcano one it would prompt me to put
my phone into the goggles now I can fly
across and look right into an active
volcano
when I was a kid and actually my brother
would always get this and I was jealous
because I wanted to play with it it's
your RC car and they have come such a
long way this is our neon giant lumitech
neon giant so great for driving the
steering on it is really simple so you
can see how I can turn it it's
customizable now because I have so many
lights on I don't think you can see the
lights in here but I have all of this
that I can take out restring different
ways I can have these lights flashing
whichever way I want to play with it and
it's just it's a lot of fun again
something I can't wait to play with this
this incorporates activity also right it
does kids are going to put it on their
wrist and they are going to raise a
digital monster everything has to do
with physical activity so for their
monster to grow up and get strong and be
healthy they have to follow challenges
that might include sprinting or Shadow
Boxing